como una historia que se repite México
volvió a registrar un terremoto en el
Estado de Michoacán esta vez de magnitud
6,9 de nuevo el sismo como a la
1:20 de la mañana en mitad de la noche
sorprendió a los mexicanos cuando ya
estaban dormidos obligando a muchos a
evacuar envueltos en mantas
este escuché que mi gatito empezó a
hacer ruido y me levanté posteriormente
empecé a escuchar la alerta sísmica
salí corriendo
fuerte Este es el segundo terremoto que
vive el país en menos de una semana algo
que tiene una explicación científica se
trata de una de las réplicas del sismo
de siete con siete grados del lunes que
son movimientos en las placas tectónicas
para reacomodarse y volver a su estado
original tras el terremoto inicial hasta
las 8 a.m del 22 de Septiembre se han
registrado 1.365
réplicas del sismo de magnitud 7,7
ocurrido en Michoacán el 19 de
septiembre la más grande fue de magnitud
6,9
aunque esta vez no hay alerta por un
posible tsunami los sismos han causado
estragos para los ciudadanos muchos
edificios y casas han sufrido daños como
en el caso de la agricultor Roberto
Verduzco que se encontró su casa en
ruinas claro
eso no
no siente más cosas No más de que se va
a acabar el mundo además de los años
materiales el terremoto también se ha
saldado con varios muertos y el miedo a
que se vuelva a repetir